one thing about humans is that we are
remarkably adaptable and we are true
omnivores whether you believe in the
carnivore diet or the vegan diet
plant-based diet I think the truth is
that humans have evolved and survived
and do so well because of their
omnivorous capacity and we do we can do
fine off eating meat and meat only
but is it optimal I don't think so we
could do we can live and survive off
eating a vegan diet is it optimal I
don't think so ok so the optimal diet is
the is the omnivore diet so whether both
sides want to agree to that or not right
it's a hot topic people need better
you've dedicated your life to it so it's
a fair say you know I've actually
dedicated my life to a diet that's
pretty radical metabolic therapy a
clinical therapy so the ketogenic diet
is very extreme and I don't think it's
it may for some people it may be optimal
obviously if you have seizures or emblem
right or something like that but is it
optimal for the athlete is it optimal I
admit I followed the diet but I every
day I eat dark chocolate and blueberries
and probably some greens and broccoli
every day too so it's not it's not a
version of a ketogenic diet that and a
person with epilepsy would follow
although are the science is evolving to
the point where the classical ketogenic
diet our understanding of it is being
[Music]
that it's maybe it was too restrictive
and that a more modified or more liberal
forms of the diet may be actually better
it definitely better for adults but in
the pediatric population it's always
prudent to start them on a on a
classical ketogenic diet with almost 90%
fat and then see how they react and then
maybe be a little bit more liberal and
transition them to kind of a diet that
I'm following okay you can also
incorporate different types of fats like
coconut oil or medium chain triglyceride
oil and perhaps even exhaust ketones but
that's still in a state of being studied
now that the introduction of those types
of fats and supplements could make it
possible that a much more liberal diet
could be followed and
maintain therapeutic ketosis which would
be have an anti seizure
your protective effects so I'm that's
that's like sort of my wheelhouse so
that's what I'm very interested in doing
because this therapy the benefits of the
ketogenic diet are not very accessible
to people because they they don't want
to exclude an entire macronutrient from
their diet which would be carbohydrates
so I think there are true benefits to
some of these plant-based foods like you
know chocolate blueberries coffee
arugula broccoli things like that
there's definitely some real benefits to
eating these foods and I think that
excluding them is not a great idea
especially for following it for the
duration of your life and some people
have to do that for their disorder so
we're trying to work and engineer diets
that would be feasible for someone to
follow but their feasibility their
efficacy may only be they may only be
efficacious when ketogenic fats and
ketone supplements are also incorporated
into the diet and we think of those
things as food like exogenous ketone a
ketone ester is a calorie containing
molecule that is kind of uni it's like a
fourth macronutrient but it can be
incorporated into the food and make that
ketogenic diet more efficacious it can
augment the therapeutic potential of
their diet in different ways so this is
an area that I study and that we are
doing research on that what are you so
what do you believe the optimal diet is
for just the average person who may not
be a professional athlete you know maybe
goes to the gym a couple days a week it
has a desk job or has just a normal 9:00
to 5:00 what would you what would you
what is your opinion on on the optimal
diet for for that kind of person yeah
well the diet that's non optimal is
probably like the majority of people
after a certain age eat too many
calories right and surplus calories will
result in sort of metabolic derangement
and type-2 diabetes and just being
overweight so we are more likely to
you eat surplus calories if it comes
from processed carbohydrates and the
combination of sugar and fat right so
sugar and fat are two things that you
want to limit in your diet the
combination of the two but fashion yeah
the combination like salt sugar and fat
but a ketogenic diet is extremely high
in fat and if you if the ketogenic diet
is by definition devoid of carbohydrates
it's the carbohydrates that can spike
the insulin and kick you outta ketosis
that makes the benefits of a ketogenic
diet it negates it so if you're on a
ketogenic diet and you have you follow
the ketogenic diet perfectly but have
you know a couple pieces of candy a day
you're not going to be getting the
benefits of the diet from a neurological
standpoint at least from an anti-seizure
sampling okay because a child could eat
one piece of candy and have a seizure
and this has been shown many times so it
kicks you out of ketosis and then you
your brain goes right back into activate
your brain in a way that triggers a
seizure we don't know exactly why this
happens okay but it depends on the
individual I guess is my point is that
if you're trying to lose weight a diet
that is formulated and that could be a
vegan diet it could be I don't think
it's optimal or it could be a carnivore
diet but I think the optimal diet for if
we're just going to make a blanket
statement yeah is a low carbohydrate
diet that's low in carbohydrates but is
sufficient enough in plants that you're
getting phytonutrients and fiber I do
believe in fiber early man had sometimes
100 150 200 grams of fiber in their diet
if you look at it depends on the period
too if you look back in history but
having studied I did study the evolution
of human diet through college and read a
number of books on it and one thing that
was like really apparent is that a lot
of fiber was he hmm
but you know a an optimal diet would be
devoid of processed carbohydrates and
sugars and sufficient in protein from
fatty cuts a beef fish poultry the beef
ideally not everybody can afford it but
from pasture raised grass-fed animals
okay I think that's obviously much
better for the environment
[Music]
concentrated feedlot operations are very
destructive to the environment and when
you're you you make a statement when you
buy your food if you're supporting this
kind of Agriculture I do believe that
GMO foods can be destructive to having
come from a farming background we are
farmers too we have had to feed the cows
in the morning and get their money so
it's been a lot of time with on the farm
and feeding counted before coming here
today and I know there are proper ways
to farm and improper ways to farm so I
think when you purchase your food you're
kind of making a statement but also
you're choosing a type of food that's
inferior if you're going in the
direction of you know your food from
factory farms so that's one
consideration there's a lot people put a
lot of time and effort looking into the
subject that's all I'm gonna say about
it for now but I think that the
macronutrient can't the macronutrients
are most important in regards to just
like human nutrition right so I'm a
believer in a higher protein diet
anywhere from I think fifteen ten to
fifteen percent is or fifteen percent is
like what the what's recommended by the
USDA or a DEA and I'm kind of more along
the lines of you know twenty to thirty
percent and with the balance being fifty
to seventy percent of my calories from
fat just because I do ketogenic diet
research and then follow the ketogenic
diet and I do get probably anywhere from
five to fifteen percent of my calories
from carbohydrates and I can thank you
ptosis with that level of carbohydrate
consumption especially if I'm
incorporating ketogenic fats or I'm
pretty active
and I have a lot of blood work to back
up that that is that's working for me
right you know there was different yeah
if you look at my blood work now you
know 45 ish and if I go back to I'm 25
my blood work at 45 is much better
[Laughter]